so continuing our coverage of all-new
all-different marvel what i want to do
here is focus on invincible Iron Man
proper and what we're going to find here
is that rather than being a title like
Spider Man that draws on previous
content instead invincible Iron Man is
largely going to be standalone what I'd
also like to point out here is that this
story may contain some spoilers for
Secret Wars
so in truth the inspiration for
invincible Iron Man comes out of Robert
Downey jr. 's portrayal of the character
as well as a return to what made our man
popular in his initial introduction what
I mean here is that while Tony Stark was
largely a background character and most
commonly recognized by non comic book
readers due to his involvement with the
Avengers when Iron Man was released in
2008 and launched the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Robert Downey jr. elevated the
character to one of Marvel's top stars
due to his devil-may-care attitude and
his wit at the same time when Iron Man
was first created in Marvel Comics he
was designed to be an adaptation of
Howard Hughes the famed billionaire
businessman inventor and philanthropist
of the 1950s and 1960s emerging during
the Vietnam War Tony Stark was designed
by Marvel to represent everything that
the youth of the time were against
military industrialism war profiteering
weapons manufacturing and the concept of
war itself while the late 1960s as well
as the 1970s and 1980s would see his
character take a different turn in terms
of his view of himself as a weapons
manufacturer to the various militaristic
agencies of the world in the end the
basis behind Tony Stark largely remained
the same and that he would flirt with
women engage in one-night stands and
generally had a lack of concern for the
personal feelings of those around him -
Pepper Potts and his chauffeur happy
Hogan this was compounded on by the fact
that like Howard Hughes Tony Stark was a
recluse in a lot of ways while he
wouldn't ignore the world as a whole due
to his responsibilities both as a
superhero and a member of the Avengers
team during his downtime his character
was most likely found in his laboratory
working on new models of the Iron Man
armor in order to combat his evolving
villains from his solo series as well as
a global threats presented in the
Avengers stories in this manner Tony
Stark's Iron Man armor was a metaphor
for who he was on a fundamental level
what I mean here is that over the course
of his publication history stories like
demon and a bottle cast aside the
superhero cover and exposed Tony Stark
for what he was a man struggling with
personal demons but for him the Iron Man
armor was an escape being able to
confine himself within an almost
indestructible body of metal meant that
while he could remain physically
protected from the various villains
around him more so than that he could
hide his perceived weakness from the
friends around him indeed while he was a
hero and fought a good fight on a
level and for reasons that we're never
truly explored Tony Stark hiding in his
Iron Man armor retreating to his
laboratory in his spare time and
splitting the superhero community down
the middle during the events of civil
war were all a reflection of the view
that he had of himself and that he
didn't believe that the man he saw in
the mirror
was a good one instead these aspects and
the reclusive nature of his life were a
reflection of his self-loathing
something that reached a fever pitch
during the events of superior Iron Man
when he found himself tumbling down the
metaphorical rabbit hole and losing
everyone that mattered him including
Pepper Potts
and so pulling the strings together and
combining the personality of Tony Stark
from the films and his personal
struggles from the comics what bindus
does here is provide us with a new line
of Iron Man stories that are just as
much about personal vindication and the
attempt to start anew as they are about
being a hero and saving the world
so invincible Iron Man initially picks
up with an unnamed man meeting a
villainous named Whitney Foss also known
as Madame masque to sidetrack for a
second Madame masque was a character
that originally appeared in tales of
suspense issue number 97 and 1968 while
she doesn't have any powers in the
traditional sense
she is prodigious in multiple forms of
martial arts as well as the art of
disguise
espionage and the use of firearms
usually keeping her face hidden under a
mask hence her name Whitney Frost and
Tony Stark's relationship is very
complicated and that during a story
titled even heroes die which had taken
place in Iron Man vol 1 issue number 18
in 1969 she had been tasked with
infiltrating Stark Industries and
incapacitating Tony Stark although she
was unsuccessful she ended up developing
an attraction to Tony and while he
initially returned her affections over
the course of their stories the two went
their own separate ways
while future events would see an
on-again off-again relationship between
the two Marvel eventually wrote her
character in a way that depicted her as
an angry ex-girlfriend which led to a
series of confrontations between the two
with Madame masque eventually returning
to her role as one of Tony Stark's
villains not transitioning back to the
story as were shown a former employee of
the terrorist group advanced idea
mechanics had defected and brought an
unidentified object with him with a deal
expected to see the item exchange for a
large sum of money Madame masque breaks
her into the bargain and kills the man
instead transitioning to Iron Man
himself
the story begins to focus directly on
Tony Stark for the duration of this
comic what mendez does here is put the
emphasis on returning Tony Stark to his
roots as an adventure what we're told is
that at some point between the end of
Secret Wars in the beginning of all-new
all-different marvel a fifteen-year-old
kid from MIT had managed to duplicate
one of his previous armors whether or
not these plans found their way onto the
black market is never really explained
here but bindus seems to hint that this
is the case with a newspaper stating
that Tony Stark is yesterday's future
furthermore following the reveal of his
armor technology stark had returned to
his laboratory for the purpose of
designing a new set of armor from the
ground up while the armor isn't given a
mark designation what we are told is
that this new suit is the best of his
previous designs connected to the brain
synapses of Stark himself this
connection allows the armor to function
seamlessly with Tony in addition to
changing its shape and color scheme
based
the mission parameters where business
initially leaves us a little ambiguous
in terms of how these changes physically
manifest the intention of Tony is to
take the other out for a test but he's
refused by his new AI now this is
something I'd like you to take
particular notice of because this will
leave some lingering questions at the
end of this issue the new AI the SARC
uses is called Friday and as a hologram
projection of someone that could be
Pepper Potts Mary Jane Watson or neither
again while we won't find out in this
comic with Ben is having previously
alluded to the idea that Mary Jane
Watson would replace Pepper Potts as the
main woman of Starks life many fans have
taken to believing that this may be a
version of pepper something that seems
to have credence since the events of
superior Ironman saw the two going their
own separate ways in addition to benda
stating that pepper would return at some
point in this new series however during
the conversation Friday reminds stark
that the new armor all needs several
hours to charge and that Tony has a date
with a woman named a Mira Pereira and
one hour transitioning to the date
Venice continues a trend of adding depth
to the roster of the Ironman cast and
the sense that America's present Adalia
intelligent but he also maintains a
comedic tone of the Iron Man comics what
I mean here is that with the two having
met at a restaurant Tony Stark had
actually reserved it for the night and
was essentially pulling out his old
tricks in an effort to impress a mirror
while she picked up on what he's doing
almost immediately and casually
dismisses it he also jokes it if he were
looking to impress her he would have
Thor accidentally show up and when
Tamara states that she would leave if he
did stark Sims Thor way in a more
serious tone though Emira is also
presented in a manner which indicates
that she seems to be someone with the
potential to keep Tony Stark grounded as
she states Tony's reputation and
accomplishments speak for itself and the
best way for the two to enjoy the
evening is for Tony to be himself and
cast aside the charade accepting his
offer
Venice establishes the intelligence of
amira and that when stark questions her
about the inventions as she's kept
private she admits that she was able to
make a cure for the mutant gene now
where some fans dislike the casual
throwaway of such an important
achievement in truth this reveal wasn't
really designed to be thrown away so
much as to illustrate the fact that
because of genetic cure for the mutant
gene which doesn't damage the mutant in
quest
was previously non-existent while this
doesn't make a merit as smart as Reed
Richards what it does do is present the
scenario that she's smarter than Tony
Stark since this is something that he's
never been able to achieve however the
day between the two was cut short when
Friday appears and for me Tony Stark
that Madame masque had returned more so
than that she's broken into Castle doom
stat and Latveria
and stolen an unknown device
transitioning to Liberia itself the home
of Doctor Doom is revealed to have been
completely demolished as Friday tells us
at some point between the end of Secret
Wars and the start of all-new
all-different marvel dr. doom had lost
control of Latveria due to his civil war
now finding himself at gunpoint at the
hands of the leader of one of the
revolutionary groups Stark initially
tried to plead his case and saying that
the purpose of his arrival is to help
them recover something that was stolen
from Castle doom and while the language
barrier presents the revolutionaries
from understanding stark the group is
suddenly met with a sonic device that
incapacitates everyone but iron man
turning to find out who it was it set
off the sonic device Friday reveals that
the person responsible is Victor Von
Doom now again this raises massive
questions regarding Secret Wars and
really serves to highlight the problem
that arises when a new event is started
before the old one ends and while I
would love to answer the questions that
you no doubt have the truth is that
until Secret Wars ends and the eight
month gap prior to all-new all-different
marvel is filled I'm essentially in the
same boat as you are with that being
said I will catch you guys later peace